[Musique]
après le retrait de la liste la
république en marche en paca au profit
de renaud muselier son parti lui à
retirer l'investiture
comment comprendre cette agressivité
alors que je combats le rassemblement
national
on prenait pas le risque de jeter une
partie des électeurs aient l'air dans
les bras de thierry mariani sur les mots
je fais ce que et il existe ce risque
dites-le vient on gagne toujours à être
honnête je ne raisonne pas comme ça moi
j'ai connu le parti de pasqua et de
seguin j'ai connu un parti qui avait des
convictions aujourd'hui je vois un
mouvement qui sait plus où il est et qui
en est à faire toute une série de
compromission cet accord c'est l'acte de
divorce définitif entre deux parties des
républicains qui étaient
irréconciliables et je vais vous dire
depuis quand
depuis le deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 ou certains ont
refusé de choisir entre le front
national et enel macron et d'autres qui
ont fait le choix de soutenir emmanuel
macron je pense aux électeurs sincère
des républicains qui sont nombreux qui
ne veulent pas être des supplétifs des
modèles macron qui doivent être
profondément troublé même un peu écoeuré
par cette petite manoeuvres d'appareil
c'est louis aliot qui m'a envoyé un
texto ce matin il main il m'a dit
gilbert la droite folle est atteinte de
la maladie de castex jacobins ce qui se
joue ici c'est la volonté du président
la république le détruire les
républicains de détruire la droite
républicaine et il a très bien expliqué
et évidemment ça pourrait se reproduire
ailleurs
donc c'est pas si vous voulez une
méthode ado qu'il faut appliquer ici
c'est une position de principe au cas où
se posera lieu
renaud muselier n'est plus que le tête
de liste de la liste en marche il s'est
placé naturellement hors de notre
famille c'est dire que ce matin et
jusque renaud muselier ne fait plus
partie de lui même du parti républicain
au moins il n'en fait plus partie
pour l est
[Rires]
c'est le petit parti politique créé par
barbara pompidou quand même un numéro 3
3 du gouvernement exactement nous
condamnons fermement l'accord en pack
ans avec renaud muselier pour faire
barrage à l'extrême droite nous devons
nous élargir à d'autres forces de
progrès pas aux conservateurs mais cette
fois je n'ai jamais jamais
j'ai demandé le soutien de ma famille
politique donc je leur demanderai le
soutien de la famille politique
conformément aux statuts que je connais
parfaitement mais je ne veux pas
d'accord d'appareil
je veux le soutien de ma famille
politique et je vais mener cette
campagne c'est une clarification
c'est à dire qu en marche et les
républicains dans la quasi totalité des
cas marchent ensemble
monsieur jacob interdit un accord au
premier tour mais sur le deuxième tour y
dit rien rendez vous entre les deux
tours si vous voulez sur ce plateau
cela veut dire qu'il n'y a pas d'accord
d'appareil qu'il n'y a pas de fusion de
listes et pour la composition de ces
listes
je donnerai la priorité au candidat qui
s'engage à se consacrer de toutes leurs
forces à des enjeux locaux et nationaux
en mai shiva où il te plait aujourd'hui
marque la fin de la limite des 10 km
pour tous les déplacements la fin des
attestations un drone en guise d'accueil
mais surtout de surveillance dans cette
commune de 30000 habitants du val de
marne alors à l'image on voit
successivement apparaître des élèves qui
reprennent les cours puis des terrasses
de restaurants et de cafés des musées
des cinémas des théâtres ouvert et même
des supporters dans des stades pas de
masse ni distanciation social mais des
sourires sur tous les visages et les
décibels à fond à liverpool pour ses
5000 spectateurs invités à participer à
un concert test oui on a tous hâte d'y
être mais ce choix de communication a
été assez mal accueillis sur twitter
quand emmanuel macron écrit nous
retrouver est ce que ça veut dire nous
retrouver avec 30 mille cas et 300 morts
par jour de mandat